[Musique]
oui
je suis très très fier et très heureux
d'inaugurer aujourd'hui ce nouveau radar
de paris saclay ce radar est un élément
essentiel de la sécurité aérienne
puisqu'il nous permet de communiquer
avec l'ensemble des avions à plus de 250
km donc soit pour les aéroports
parisiens mais aussi les autoroutes du
ciel au dessus de paris
c'est un élément essentiel de notre
réseau de sécurité aérienne françaises
outre le symbole je pense de modernité
pour l'établissement par rapport à
l'ancien radar de palaiseau ce radar est
beaucoup plus haut et c'est l'oeil de
l'aviation civile donc le fait d'avoir
une élévation suffisante permet
d'accompagner le développement de
paris-saclay sans que sa vision soit
masqué et donc nous son altitude assez
élevé sa performance
après c'est l'oeil et c'est un système
qui s'intègrent particulièrement bien
dans son environnement
du point de vue architectural je crois
que y'a qu'à voir la qualité
architecturale qu'on se rencontre mais
du point de vue aussi de l'environnement
électromagnétique
j'insiste sur cet aspect oeil c'est une
technologie de l'aviation civile qui
s'appelle le radar secondaire c'est à
dire que ce radar travail en
interrogation réponses avec les avions
et avec des puissances d'émission très
faible ce qui est une grande différence
notamment avec les radars militaires de
détection qui eux doivent pouvoir
détecter n'importe quel as tu lu et donc
en voie d émission à la beaucoup plus
forte
ça ce sont des émissions très faible de
communication avec les avions ce qui
permet d'insérer ce radar dans un
environnement urbain sans absolument
aucun problème de sécurité
que nous étions à la fois dans notre
modernisation mais aussi en
accompagnement pour pouvoir intégrer ce
radar dans l'environnement et
l'établissement public a travaillé pour
nous comme maître d'ouvragé délégué les
crédits sont du ministère des transports
mais l'établissement public avait
effectivement fait une maîtrise courage
remarquable ce qui a permis de tenir des
délais et de mettre en service ce radar
depuis le mois de juillet
sans aucun problème de mise en service
c'est vraiment une réussite de
coopération entre l'aviation civile et
l'établissement saclay